ubisoft is ending support for ghost
recon break point ubisoft might have a
new battle royale and lara croft is
ending her vacation
the day has come ghost recon breakpoint
will no longer be supported ubisoft made
the announcement in a twitter update and
said quote the last four months have
marked the release of our final piece of
content but don't mourn the game just
yet you can get in plenty of playtime
still ubisoft said it will continue to
maintain the servers for both wildlands
and break point until further notice
over the last several months ghost recon
breakpoint content began winding down
with the launch of operation mother lode
mode anniversary content that celebrated
the 20th anniversary of the series in
2021 and the controversial quartz nfts
that received a lot of consumer backlash
as for the future of the franchise ghost
recon frontline will carry the brand
forward it's a first-person battle
royale focused multiplayer entry into
the series that focuses on teams of
players battling it out to find crucial
intel and extract them from the
battlefield before it's too late but
that isn't yubi's only battle royale in
the works a new report states that a new
third-person hero shooter take on the
genre tentatively titled pathfinder is
reportedly in early stages of
development at ubisoft montreal the
report comes from tom henderson who says
he's seen images and videos of the game
in action and it looks similar to
ubisoft's almost dead battle royale
hyperscape but more cartoony in nature
pathfinder is said to be a pvpve take on
battle royale with players having to
battle both ai enemies and other
competitors as they work their way
towards the center of the map to defeat
a boss-like enemy to reach the boss in
the center players will need to breach
an outer and inner wall via a series of
gates that change on a per-match basis
henderson reports that the game will be
a hero shooter in that there will be
different playable characters to choose
from that each have their own unique
abilities pathfinder will also
reportedly have a destiny-like social
space where players can shop test out
weapons at a firing range join events
and interact with other players
pathfinder is coming from the same
studio that made hyperscape which is set
to shut down on april 28th personally i
think ubisoft should slow down with
these shooters the company said it would
learn from the mistakes of hyperscape
but pumping out frontline pathfinder and
ex-defiance soonish seems like they're
just throwing games at the wall praying
one sticks long enough to be a
competitor for warzone fortnite or
overwatch let me know in the comments if
you think i'm way off base with that
tape but in some non-ubisoft news laura
croft saw the uncharted movie and
thought you've gone too far nate my
hiatus is over during epic's state of
unreal event crystal dynamics confirmed
that it has begun work on the next tomb
raider game and that it will run on
unreal engine 5. the studio added quote
our goal is to push the envelope of
fidelity and to deliver the high quality
cinematic action adventure experience
that fans deserve from both crystal
dynamics and the tomb raider franchise
this will be the first new entry in the
series since 2018's shadow of the tomb
raider which was developed by idah's
montreal and wrapped up the events of
the new trilogy that started in 2015. i
fell off the new trilogy and never got
around to playing shadow but my wife is
a huge fan of all three and immediately
wanted a release date for this new one
when i told her it was announced so
congrats tomb raider fans i'm sure this
game is gonna be sick however if it
comes out around the same time as the
new witcher i'm gonna have to toss it on
the backlog cause monster slang comes
first
i'll see you tomorrow
you